et cet invité ses vous stéphane ligue 1
bonjour
bonjour comment allez vous mais très
bien et vous êtes en direct depuis
genève vous dirigez le cyber peace
institute une ong qui en gros depuis
trois ans analyse les attaques
informatiques à travers le monde offre
des conseils à ceux qui peuvent en être
victimes et avant cela vous avait
notamment travaillé pour europol celle
agence européenne de police criminelle
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à vous êtes dans une voiture
pour les questions techniques parce que
c'est plus simple comme ça mais en tout
cas on vous voit bien où vous entends
bien et ça c'est l'essentiel le 24
février dernier une heure avant les
premiers bombardements russes en ukraine
moscou lancé son offensive numérique
pour paralyser les satellites ukrainien
pirater les les grands ministères à kiev
on va parler ensemble de cette civette
cyberguerre de cette guerre dans la
guerre en ukraine est-ce qu'on a d'abord
une idée de l'ampleur de cette guerre
que se livrent l'ukraine la russie et
leurs alliés
alors merci merci pour l'invitation et à
votre question c'est difficile de donner
des chiffres de
la problématique des attaques numériques
des cyberattaques c'est que souvent
elles mettent beaucoup de temps être est
détectée et est comptabilisée est ce que
l'on sait c'est que depuis l'invasion et
même avant l'invasion russe en ukraine
il ya une recrudescence d'attaqués
numérique sur tous les fronts en ce qui
concerne ce conflit donc on en a
plusieurs types d'attaqués vous avez des
attaques dormant pour détruire les
systèmes sont attaqués ont été
déclenchées même avant l'invasion
attaquant fait pour détruire
l'infrastructure et empêcher des
capacités ukrainienne dans ce dans ce
cadre de dans ce cas d'école de pouvoir
être être opérationnel dans un premier
type d'attaqué des attaques pour
détruire il ya ensuite des attaques qui
ont été mis en place pour empêcher
l'accès à des services essentiels à la
population ukrainienne dont les attaques
sur le service de santé les attaques sur
les services bancaires on a vu des
attaques sur les services numériques
utilisés pour faciliter l'extraction et
l'aide apportée aux réfugiés donc ça
c'est extrêmement problématique dans une
période de tension de tension
humanitaire et vous avez les attaques
qui sont en fait sur l'espace
informationnel
lequel la guerre a lieu et c'est des
attaques de désinformation de propagande
de fausses nouvelles qui sont là pour
déstabiliser la confiance souvent dans
de la population ukrainienne envers
leurs capacités ou les soins humanitaire
qui leur sont prodigués et alors qui
sont les protagonistes de deux de ces
attaques est ce que ce sont bien je sais
pas d d d d armée de pirates qui sont
parfaitement organisé est ce que ce sont
des actions collectives individuelles
comment est ce que ça fonctionne
alors ces nombreux acteurs qui sont
actifs dans ce domaine dont très
clairement et nous l'avons vu dans le
passé ce qui se passe aujourd'hui une
action qui est très clairement militaire
donc ils étaient synchronisés avec
l'action sur le terrain sont des
attaques qui sont dans dans le temps
dans le contexte militaire de
l'offensive mais vous avez également des
attaques qui sont perpétrés par des
groupes criminels et des groupes
criminels qui le disent publiquement
donc quelques quelques heures après
l'invasion un groupe criminel spécialisé
dans le rang songy ciel conti fait une
déclaration publique qu'il prendrait
fait et cause pour les capacités russe
dans ce conflit est d'ailleurs ce ce
groupe criminel est encore actif
aujourd'hui tenant un état en otage
l'état du costa rica oui parce qu'il
faut rappeler quelque chose stéphane
huguen c'est le mode opératoire en
russie c'est un peu particulier certes
les hackers ne font pas partie de l'état
russe il ne travaille pas pour lui mais
on voit une espèce d'accord tacite
autres le kremlin et e on vous laisse
faire vos activités criminelles mais le
jour où le kremlin a besoin de vous vous
répondrai tout de suite présent à
l'appel c'est ça hein alors c'est un peu
des deux vous avez une capacité qu'une
capacités étatiques et qui étaient mise
en oeuvre dans nombre d'attaqués au
cours de ces dernières années on peut
penser par exemple à l'attack solarwinds
qui étaient attribués aux acteurs
étatiques aux capacités en fait les
militaires et aux capacités de russes
donc dirigé par l'état mais dans le même
temps en parallèle vous avez également
un écosystème en fait grandissant depuis
depuis plus d'une décennie deux groupes
criminels qui sont basés en russie où
qui profite en tout cas de capacités
capacité russe et qui ont pour
doctrine depuis depuis des années de ne
pas attaquer les intérêts russes et
d'employer des criminels russophone est
aujourd'hui dans une période de tension
ou tous et toutes prennent parti et
position dans le cadre de cette de cette
invasion sa rentrée d'une prolifération
des attaques et une activité accrue de
tous ces groupes tous ces groupes pardon
dans le même cyber espace alors du côté
ukrainien comment ça se passe il y à il
ya des hackers ukrainien d'ailleurs
l'ukraine est assez connu pour ça pour
être à ses pointures on donne dans le
cyber et puis aussi des alliés
occidentaux comme moi ce que tout ça se
coordonnent alors c'est la grande
le grand palais le point d'interrogation
de ceux de ce conflit qu'elle va être
l'escaladé à quel point dans le
cyberespace peu de jours après
l'invasion les ukrainiens ont rappelé un
volontariat un volontariat numérique ils
ont appelé à ce qu'ils étaient en
capacité sur leur territoire dd à
l'effort de défense
de l'infrastructure ukrainienne mais cet
appel n'a pas été entendu qu'en ukraine
et détendue bien au-delà donc
aujourd'hui vous avez des des acteurs
qui utilisent leurs capacités
personnelles voire leurs infrastructures
leurs infrastructures étatiques mais
dans des pays qui ne sont pas parties au
conflit et ses acteurs c'est ces hackers
ou les appeler comme vous voulez
participent à des actions d'antan
d'ensemble d'attaqués contre des cibles
militaires et ce faisant se retrouvent
parties au conflit et ça ça change
complètement la dynamique du conflit en
fait ce qui se passe depuis l'invasion
russe en ukraine c'est un changement
dans le temps et dans l'espace de cette
guerre dans le temps parce que des cyber
attaques qui ont été faites bien avant
l'invasion un impact direct sur l'effort
de guerre et dans l'espace parce que
presque tout à chacun autour de la
planète peut participer dans le
cyber-espace à ce conflit
sont le pai avoir d' attaques
informatiques de très grande envergure
par exemple n'y a pas de paralysie de
centrales nucléaires on redoutait sarah
blocage d'aider des centrales à distance
par exemple est ce que finalement une
grande cyberattaques c'est pas un peu
comme la bombe atomique sorte d' arme de
dissuasion d'armes de dernier recours
parce qu'on sait que ça peut se
retourner contre soi même
alors il faut bien comprendre qu'une
cyber attaque s'inscrit dans le temps il
peut y avoir les attaques en cours qui
n'ont pas encore détecté et c'est tout
l'objet de ces attaques c'est de
permettre d'infiltrer les systèmes de se
positionner dans system pendant
suffisamment longtemps pour être pour
avoir l'impact le plus important le jour
où ça a un intérêt dans la stratégie
militaire donc soyons soyons prudents
ceci étant dit il est aussi important de
souligner que si il n'y avait pas de
temps d'horreur il faut il faut les
nommer de
d'exactions de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
l'ampleur des cyber attaques seraient
vus différemment il y a énormément
énormément de campagne de cyber attaques
depuis cette invasion donc beaucoup plus
que ce qui se passait en termes de
tension dans cette région avant avant
février donc il faut nuancer le constat
maintenant oui nous avons pas vu de
cyberattaques qui ont mis un billet à
mal des systèmes dans de grandes
ampleurs sauf au tout début alors qu'une
cyber-attaque avait ciblé les systèmes
de télécommunication satellite et on a
bien vu le risque de ce genre d'attaqué
qu'il ciblait des infrastructures en
ukraine et s'est retrouvé impacts et des
infrastructures en europe notamment en
france voire même des systèmes de
commande de deux éoliennes en allemagne
est ce que les pays qui sont plus en
pointe que d'autres en la matière des
pays où où on sait mener des
cyberattaques et où on se prépare être
attaqué par l'adversaire alors sur une
capacité qui était développé très
différemment dans différents pays vous
avez des pays qui sont qui sont qui sont
en pointe depuis depuis des années comme
par exemple la russie les états unis
vous parlez de la capacité numérique
informatique de l'ukraine l'ukraine est
une stratégie de numérisation
extrêmement avancé ce qui peut expliquer
leur capacité à se défendre en ce qui
concerne ces attaques voilà selon selon
les régions les niveaux sont différents
après pour certains pays
aussi toute la problématique il ya une
une a recours à des groupes là qui sont
des groupes de sociétés privées pour
apporter un soutien aux capacités ou de
défense ou capacités offensives merci
merci beaucoup stéphane duguay nous
avoir éclairé sur ces questions je
rappelle que vous dirigez le cyber peace
institute est d'ailleurs à ce titre j'en
profite pour dire vous partie ypres et
demain à lille au forum international
sur la cyber sécurité qui va réunir
beaucoup de dirigeants du secteur et
notamment ce contexte de la guerre en
ukraine ça dure plusieurs jours et c'est
très intéressant merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin et merci à mon choisy
france 24